[Music]
welcome to another episode of i've got a
question today's question is what is the
difference in obedience and legalism
well that's an interesting question and
seemingly non-media related but if you
watch our videos we're always talking
about how there's a common theme in many
videos about rebellion to god
so should we be obedient to god or is
that a legalistic construct when we do
some command that god has issued
a simple definition of legalism is
essentially putting law above the gospel
let's ponder a very simple and profound
thought
what is the gospel
you're probably saying well it's the
good news and you know what you're right
but the good news about what
well it's the good news that jesus died
for our sins which is not only correct
and not just good news it's the best
news
but continue to follow me
what is sin
the bible answer comes from 1st john 3
4. it says whoever commits sin also
commits lawlessness and sin is
lawlessness
now let's think back to the first
instance of sin
what happened
well god had asked adam and eve to do
something it says this
and the lord god commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden you
may freely eat but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil you may not
eat for in the day that you eat of it
you shall surely die
in the simplest sense this was law
god had spoke god expected to be obeyed
now continuing to keep the law would not
save them
only the atoning sacrifice could do that
but do you think they walked away from
this experience looking to disobey more
frequently
they realized that obedience was for
their own benefit
and that's exactly what we see in
deuteronomy 6 24 it says in the lord god
commanded us to observe all these
statutes to fear the lord for our good
always that he might preserve us alive
as it is this day
the difference in obedience and legalism
is really revealed in relationship do
you obey because you have to
or because you want to do you obey
because you want to be saved
or because you are
you see the law cannot save you only the
blood of jesus can do that
but we also cannot expect to be saved if
we have a rebellious attitude toward
christ and what he asks us to do in his
word
now let's bring this back to media if
there are things that god has asked us
not to put before our eyes is that being
legalistic
no it's simply doing what god asks for
our own benefit
you know i hope that you're learning to
trust your heavenly father in all things
and i encourage you to follow god and
what he has asked in his word we also
hope that you will check out some of our
other questions and that they are
providing some sound biblical counsel
please share them on social media with
your family and friends who may have
voiced these same questions and if
there's some media related question that
has you stumped
please feel free to reach out to us by
email or social media and we'll see if
we can tackle it thanks and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you